now I hope you guys are really ready for
some tough stuff because I have prepared
some really challenging stuff for today
we are going to do a bunch of middle
game positions and we're going to do
some what I hope to be fun stuff as well
and of course we'll always finish with
something kind of as a dessert
something very aesthetic that is kind of
the amazing side of chess but again this
and we're going to start with a missed
opportunity all right this is actually
the position we're going to start with
and this is a position from a real game
and in the game white played a certain
move and the game ended with a certain
result but after the game Monday at the
players analyzed they realize that white
missed a superb opportunity here are
real golden opportunity and let's see if
you guys can can figure it out right now
we can see if we look at them appeals we
see that the blocking is not super safe
right the White King definitely looks
like his total picture of safety and the
black is behind in development he has a
rock on a 8 a bishop and c8 that are
very clumsy and black also has a rock on
the 7th on a 2 looks like a very
dangerous rock attacking the bishop on
on a 3 all looking very very cool of
course white played paid a dear price
right he's done an exchange in a point
that's almost the equivalency of a whole
piece to get to this position he became
really worried about his position so he
decided that maybe this is a good time
to bail and that's what he did
we'll talk about what I mean by that if
it's if it's a bit puzzling to you right
now so what to even do I mean if you
just move your bishop away somewhere
then at the least I can just develop you
complete my development and the material
advantage is going to tell you need to
be a little creative here take a look at
all the pieces and try to think yourself
what what do you think we should do here
ok
very interesting Queen to e5 okay but
we'll see what the point is Queen to e5
in this position that's what he played
in the game and now of course he has a
million threads in this position we can
see that he is trotting for example
Brooke g6 may be winning the Queen and
black really was afraid of what's going
on because white is also threatening to
play stuff like Bishop c5 Bishop d4
right black is so cramped here if I get
to play Bishop here and Bishop here end
of the game you're going to get made it
and also as a bonus I'm threatening
sometimes Ruby sex so he decided to take
this bishop and he played Queenie a
check notice that this is not such a
good idea because if we take here and
takes back and Queen takes here black
has two rooks for a queen and let's say
I take here and now my passport looks
very very annoying so this is not a good
solution this is white is probably still
losing here the pawn is too strong in
two rocks at this kind of a position
there are good match for the Queen so
but why it said okay I don't I'm not
pretty modest he played check and they
agree to a draw simply because after
here he plays check and the King if the
King goes here then check if Queen f6
Queen takes the King cannot escape a
perpetual check so the to the players
agree to a draw and everybody was well
temporary happy temporarily happy so
after this the question is what would
have been a better move and I will
reveal the move to you and let's see if
you guys can follow it up with why that
little difference would have made all
the difference in the game Queen f6
looks like a really crazy move in this
position well we understand that if the
black bishop moves then white is just
going to play Bishop to here and then
Bishop to d4 and there's going to be
just mates all over the dark squares
this is just an easy win so like Bishop
e6 Bishop c5 and Bishop d4 this is
winning for white easily but what would
have happened the same like before what
they would have happened if you just
take the bishop I mean we already said
that if you win the Queen for the rock
then it's not enough you have to work
for the Queen but there is a follow up
again what I'm hoping that you will pick
up from this kind of a position is that
don't stop calculating too soon like in
this position you can just say oh if I
take the bishop then rook da check Queen
takes Queen takes I move my king to g7
and life is just grand for me I have no
problems I have two rooks for a queen
and I'm attacking this pawn maybe this
time I don't have the passer but at
least I'm not losing block all I have to
do is complete my development and my
life is going to be wonderful but what
did white what did my white miss white
miss some something I'm sure it if he
saw Queen e5 he must have seen Queen f6
and he probably thought that he doesn't
want to play the ending he missed
something very very nice what did he
miss let me show you this is really very
nice so if takes the bishop then rook da
check winning the Queen okay that's
normal
takes takes King g7 so we bought B also
until here and we know that the two
rooks are okay as a match for the Queen
except that White had a beautiful little
trick here
Queen to d4 Jack doesn't matter if the
King goes to g8 or f6 or h6 do whatever
you want let's say King J the most
unwitting move and now white plays Queen
B tomb and the rook is trapped the rook
is a goner
so again both sides missed up one side
allowed that the other side didn't see
it so but after the game and analyzed I
don't know if somebody showed it to them
or they just figured out by themselves
but that would have been a real pretty
finish to Brooke a whole rook is trapped
in the corner
there's just no moves 1 2 3 4 you lose
them after all of them gain over are we
clear on this one okay call now I'm
going to show you what I think is a very
unusual situation I'm going to show you
an opening that goes all the way to the
ending and amazingly it's going to go
all the way to a winning ending let me
show you how that's done sometimes we
play logical moves developing moves we
think that we play a perfect game and we
make a little concession we don't
appreciate how bad it is but this is
just the beauty of chess look so it's a
normal opening and Italian game we must
have seen this a million times maybe
even I'm sure some of you even played it
right white black or even football cars
93 one of many variations Knight f6 D 3
d 6 Bishop to g5 Knight a5 ok one of the
moves that is possible another common
possibilities to play 8 6 kind of hoping
that the bishop will go to h4 and then
you'll hit him with g5 and the bishop
will end up in oblivion on g3 since
black hasn't committed his king he's not
going to castle this way so usually
after eight six the bishop takes the
Queen takes the knight hops to d5 for
King the Queen and the pawn the Queen
will retreat to d8 and then white will
cover the d4 square by pushing the pawn
to c3 that's another variation here
black played not a5 that almost always
used to be a safe line for equality
because the knight gets rid of the good
bishop
if the bishop goes Czech then Bishop g7
nothing really super alarming so white
plays Bishop to b3 ok no problem and I
took it and the a pawn took of course
towards the center opening the a file
right now when we look at the position
we are not super excited we think hey
Black has two bishops and an easy game
and he completed his developed
everything is just cool white plays
Knight a4 we understand this idea just
like your opponent wanted to trade the
knight for the bishop we want to do the
same that Bishop is a strong piece let's
trade it now watch what happened black
played eight six Bishop h4 okay notice
that now things are a bit different
after g5 I'm less worried about putting
my bishop to g3 but still I think they
should have done it right here instead
watch what happened Bishop to g4 pinning
deny trying to take advantage improving
the position of the bishop but this move
is a bad mistake and now the game gets
really nice watch what why does he
forces the trades of all the minor
pieces and at rest you think Hague is
just going towards the draw black is
just going to have one extra set of
double points how could this be enough
for a win but that's what's nice about
just watch first of all eliminating the
bishop that's easy pawn takes now notice
the pawn on e5 is very vulnerable by the
knight albeit the knight is pinned to
the queen by that bishop so white put
the question to the bishop what you what
are you going to do well the bishop
doesn't have that many choices if he
tries to stay on the diagonal maintain
the pin we just kick it out
when the bishop retreats the pawn is
ours for the taking the same thing is
going to happen if the bishop retreats
on the long diagonal so having said a he
is forced to say B and y takes back now
we have a lot of pressure against this
pawn against this Knight excuse me if
you push the pawn to g5 in the game you
just played Queen d6 but if you pushes
the pawn here then the bishop is
attacking this pawn let's say you
defended somehow I don't know maybe
Queen d6 or something now I can play my
Queen to f5 and White has an enormous
advantage watch that Queen and
untouchable Queen now you probably have
to play something very passive like this
and White has a huge advantage for
example I don't know maybe h4 looks like
a really nice move to make here nothing
to take the pawn if you take my row
comes Duda
and well black looks really really sad
in this position notice that he cannot
even easily cancer because remember that
open file my rook is going to gulp that
pawn in one second so we understand this
part so instead after Queen takes he
decided to play Queen to d6 unpinning
the knight and why it said okay I'm
taking it if you take with the pawn you
really have not much relief because with
Queens on the board and such weak pawn
structure then my attacking chances
increase again I will just castle and I
don't think black is going to be so
thrilled to castle here and on the other
hand he can't easily castle here because
again the pawn is going to be loose so
he played Queen takes trying to relieve
some of the pressure
why Turk and blackjack so far
everybody's yawning right we have this
was a most boring opening and we in
speeding fashion we have arrived at the
ending but if black thought that this is
going to be a simple draw even material
and no really open files or anything
then I can already reveal to you this is
near lost black is on a verge of a loss
and if you are puzzled why then this is
why we are here we have gathered here to
look at it and now I'm going to hush up
for just a tiny bit of time let's see if
you can tell me what will be the first
step improving the disposition is very
bad for black you have to try to form a
plan and maybe the first move you can
see or but the question is can you
really see the whole plan very
instructive way because here you might
play some let's say King e2 or castles
and kill maybe the game can let maybe
black can improve his position maybe the
game will end in a draw not going to be
it's not going to be too bad so I'm
going to leave you to think for a bit
let me hear you think out loud like what
Kennedy pawns are looking at don't be
shy suggest ideas even if they're not
concrete or they don't work let's see
together what putt moves or move moves
or move or moves are you thinking about
okay so in other words you want to
improve like help straighten you uh-huh
oh you want to cancel very good okay now
we're talking something else so you
understand that the move f4 is a good
break for white and you are right but
watch how why does it white is doing it
in an improved version he knows it I can
play f4 right now by the way because I'm
pretty certain that black is not going
to take right after I Castle and I'm
going to regain the pawn momentarily and
then I'm going to have a field day
against your weak bones right here right
so I can play out for at once but before
I go F or I want to do more damage in
the position I have the ability because
when I go f4 and the black king is going
to come and defend me be the black king
is going to end up like on this square
then all you'll need is just one rook to
defend the rest the king is going to be
a very active defender agreed yeah so
how do i lure the King away watch what
he did he went through a five beautiful
this is really clever just in my opinion
he is attacking the C pawn well I don't
see many ways to defend it except the
move that he played in a text which was
b6 otherwise any other move I'm just
going to say rook takes pawn thank you
very much
right easy so you played the move B sex
creating a weakness and now rook a6
making sure that this guy is not moving
too far and this is a target you can
already tell what do I want to do now if
I'm white
pile up again I want to castle and then
bring my F rook to a-1 and bye-bye pawn
agreed and there is no way to defend it
I'm to move basically I'm castles Andrew
k1 and opponent a7 is gone I'm up upon
in the ending with all the fun in the
world right
what is blacks only way to try to defend
it you got it hold it somehow what is
the only piece that can support this on
time
I agree I agree well your alternative is
to try to play your rook to here and
here I don't think that this is a good
long-term solution right because you
will not be able to make any moves both
MOOCs will never move ever I'm just I
can always mark time with my rook to
waste time if I need to in the meantime
I'm going to play f4 bring my king into
the game well obviously this is just
losing in the long run so black had to
play King d7 white castles normally in
positions like this in the endgame the
king is a very active piece and we play
king e to or king d2
we want to keep the king close to the
center but we already know why the idea
is with castling we want to be able to
play a4 and the rook is already
ready-made behind it for that kind of
activity
my first threat however is rook fa1
winning upon winning the game the black
king must move itself further from the
king side and now white hits with the
move f4 you understand what happened
here
I was not winning the pawn on a7 or
anything in this position but I was
luring the King away from defending the
e pawns the E and F pawns the only way
was to rush and rush and now that the
king is away now I'm playing the move f4
okay black tried to kick the rook away
from this unknowing square so he can
also free his a rock and white went all
the way back he has nothing else to look
for on the file no need to go elsewhere
and now you have to do something guess
what I'm threatening pawn takes pawn
takes rook takes f7 extra pawn and a
winning position so he played rook h7 he
needs to live a look on the h4 because
we know that even this guy is very
vulnerable if he would have played rook
to f8 I would have taken taken and rook
h6 rook f6 and the pawn on h6 is already
starting to suffer a lot so white says
all right I'm going to under buy your
pawns because I want to open the file
for my guys
so he took took rook f6 one rook is
already in the arena the other one is
about to follow he
played here okay of course the true KF
one would have been okay he decided to
play this move first he could have also
done it immediately that's not really a
big deal only moved to defend upon the
other rook is coming over to tickle f7
Black has another no brainer now he
repeated the position he played here
here simply intending to play f6 so you
play back and he played back and now he
played g4 he just repeated once for good
measure
now the one on g4 make sure that
opponent h5 has no grander ideas of
advancing god forbid and watch how those
two rooks are going to cause disaster
those pawns are just so loose the
weaknesses are here here and here and
you cannot do anything on this side
desperately he's trying to bring the
King back check here what else he has to
be active because white is going to play
the next maneuver anyways what do you
think how do we pile up against the
pawns look how passive the black rooks
are this rook is a full capacity but we
need to do something with this guy so
use your imaginary hand thing that you
have it what would you like to put it
like if you can put it on any square on
the board where would you put it right
now what is the most promising Square
for the rock let's say here I'll pick it
up with my mouse where do I want it I
can have it anywhere what would I want
it say again a4 but then what let's say
here then what am I going to do what is
my follow up I want it where you can
start picking up pawns so where can I
put it it's going to pick up once what
is my final destination say again
against e8 and what is my follow-up not
easy to get it upon its protective well
I wanted here obviously right if I get
to h5 then how you defend all your pawns
so that's what he does
rook to f5 black is in real trouble here
in the game he played a 4 and that lost
it would have been interesting to play
the move King before but look watch how
white is just calmly ignoring this King
F to b5 that's the idea to try to push
the pawns create some weaknesses rook to
c6 a beautiful little pawn that make
sure that black doesn't have any c4
ideas a4 and now comes a beauty white is
not going to take the pawn on a4 because
then if you take and the pawn takes then
maybe a3 and the King will take and then
the King is going to penetrate and start
tickling the chain from under but White
has a beautiful tactical defense watch
it King III what the heck is going on
isn't black attacking the pawn on b3
twice and it's already defended once and
by doing so he is going to permit the
King to enter no there's a beautiful
matin app if you even dream about taking
this pawn which is a blunder check the
king will run away to the a file here or
a for years even worse and now why to
move checkmate in one three moves
that's right back home threatening rook
to a one mate
I have only one move to avoid them it
immediately and that is to create an
escape script for my king
how does why take that away from him c4
and next move is Roque one checkmate the
King is just trapped in a mousetrap
there's a Maitre and may threaten anyone
there's no way you can stop it so even
the activity with the pond does not work
for black nothing works the weaknesses
are just all over look at the clumsiness
of the rooks on eight seven and a seven
so back we go to that position and after
rook f5 he played a four so now white
calmly took it and the king took it
Andrew cage five the pawns are starting
to fall c4
I don't know what else to suggest
because if you don't try to do something
very aggressive I'm going to take on
eighty six then I'm going to just go
back and attack more pawns and I'm going
to my H bone is going to be come on
stores so the two either this takes King
here Turk Turk Turk look here again
seeking activity what else to do and why
it says okay I'm on your pawn king Chuck
King f2 rook check King III of course
the h-bomb is very important if you just
bother to take this silly C pawn then
I'm going to be able to guard both my
pawns when they spawn and March them to
Queenie
so check and takes check here check here
here here
white his upper pond and he's just going
to win material easily rook here
Ruki seven attacking another pawn what's
the only way to defend of course play f6
and now white plays a move that wins
both pawns g5 beautiful removing the
defender he had to take check here now
like his up two points and of course the
rest is very easy check
year row here b3 row here you cannot
defend the C pawn but okay we'll take
the other one row here here and white
went on to win of course King and two
points like that against with a rock of
course it's a very very simple meant so
again from the opening what did we see a
boring opening all the minor pieces and
the Queen's were traded there was one
extra weakness for black on the King
side both sides had double pawns on the
other side and that was already enough
to create a winning advantage by opening
lights at a rock keeping the King busy
on one hand and then f4 with the
penetration of our rooks no defense okay
now that we saw something technical
we're going to move to something a
little more aggressive I would say let's
take a look at this and this is a very
interesting position a middlegame
position let's take a look at that we
obviously see that white has a better
position that's no secret
he is castled black is not both sides
have two minor pieces developed and the
Queen developed of course white is also
a little more space but the white bishop
is attacked on g5 what are we going to
do we have to think to ourselves what
can be done in this position if I'm just
going to move the bishop away especially
let's say to h4 to try to maintain the
pin black he's going to kick with g5
break the pin and close any chances of
white opening the file the bishop will
retreat and back will black will just
castle comfortably the storm is over if
he manages to cancel that's going to be
pretty good when we look at this
position we also have to bring out a
consideration to the game black just
wants to castle either he or he is dying
to escape we need to think of hot what
resources are we going to have in order
to try to prevent that so also I want
you to look at your pieces and think
which pieces do we like and which pieces
do we not like well pieces that we like
has to be the Queen the bishop and the
rook on the air file those are pieces we
really like
the business we don't like is the night
on v2 that is very clumsy right now and
the roeckl a one that hasn't moved black
on the other hand is just in defensive
mode
he has no pieces beyond the third rank
and even this one is pinned of course
he's done to just somehow Castle and try
to keep as many lines closed as possible
material is dead even what would you
play here if you were white Bishop takes
f6 again trying to trade and of course I
have to take back with the bishop
knowing I can take with the Queen and
then maybe you can take on g6 and the
pawn will take back and then you think
yourself and now what right now what
because again black is just going to
Castle so again I don't want to make the
moves because some of them move always
pops and I hate that but we can just use
it without moving the pieces Bishop
takes Bishop takes pawn takes pawn takes
and again we have reached some sort of a
dead end it's like we just missing the
extra firepower if only we could
activate our pieces further but by then
it's too late
so I want you to watch and see what why
did why just decided that he's going to
do what we call in chess a clearance
sacrifice and he played a five brilliant
that's a very clever move at first it
looks like what are you doing he can
take with a pawn of course if he takes
with a queen rook e1 we all know it's
going to be disaster but you can just
take with the pawn and then it seems
like that the file is even closed more
closed than before what is the big deal
about it well we know that after pawn
takes Bishop pawn takes Knight followed
by rook e1 check that doesn't look happy
right that just doesn't look good for
black there's not much to look at but
what happened if he does takes it what
will we achieve by sacrificing the form
well now we're taking the knight and the
bishop has to take back we are taking
the pawn to further open the file and
black has to take back and now we bring
our Knight to e4 now we understand the
purpose of the clearance the doofy night
that was doing nothing
for is now the hero of the day he comes
straight to the center of the board
attacking the bishop and now the rukon
f1 is also attacking the bishop notice
that that Bishop all of a sudden becomes
clumsy if even they're thinking of
moving he whether let's say Bishop g7 is
even worse but let's try Bishop g5 okay
then White has a fantastic move let's
see if one of you can figure it out take
a good look at the position I think
that's also good 96 check if the Queen
takes Queen f7 right and maybe rook to
d1 after that and maybe you'll have to
play Bishop d2 I'm positive that even
this is good for white but we can do it
in reverse order
rook f7 smashing just a smashing move if
you even dream about taking hello 96
with a Royal fork winning immediately if
you don't take well where are you going
to put your queen to prevent my queen
from coming to e6 and my Knight to d6
and well no black and just go home right
it's over so that's out but that Bishop
still need to do something we need to do
something about it it's under attack the
knight is attacking the rook is
attacking what is the only move I have
left yeah it's a no brainer I have to go
here now again before we even look for a
move we can just enjoy the position and
see that for one pawn for one little
pawn we have so much play here every one
of our pieces is better the Queen is
better than the Queen the Minor is
better than the [ __ ] tonight is better
than the bishop the rook on f1 is better
than the rock on f8 and of course the
rooks are on the a file kind of cancel
each other out of course the main thing
is the King stuck in the center while my
king on g1 is just super safe but I'll
tell you what fall asleep for one move
black is going to go left Castle life is
going to be much harder again if you
wanted to play rook A to D one who can
fold here again a decent move but here
white played a very mature continuation
because he realized that he's going to
trade one advantage for another and even
though maybe
it's going to physically be a little
difficult to play the moose because you
think oh do I really want to have to do
that but when you see what you're
getting for it it'll be hard to resist
say again
okay so Brooke takes Knight Queen takes
Queen f8 okay I'm up guaranteeing unit
if I put the computer he is going to
love white in that position but you know
me I'm a big believer in overkill and
chess I demand the best so this is
sufficient you could win with your
continuation it's very good but I demand
the best but you'll be surprised that
your first idea was right
what watch what we're doing we are
giving up that super Knight and the
great rook for that silly Bishop at the
other rook but we are not doing it for
no reason this is not just a simple
trade this is again trading one big
advantage for another watch what happens
he took Turk Turk Chuck and that dormant
rook goes straight into the game and in
this position black has to resign
because it's all over you cannot stop
all my threats of course if the Queen
goes to e7
I'm going to go Queen to GA check
picking up the rook in the corner if you
try to go to g7 to stop those checks my
Queen visits right here and it's all
done Queen seven Queen g8 wins a rock
King v8 at a minimum I have this
threatening mate and the Queen winning
the Queen came over so even though we
really cherished and admire our Knight
and rook where they were and that Bishop
was so useless and the rook is so
passive here we understand that by
trading just the bishop for a knight the
second trade of rook for a rook is not
this rook that we trade for the FA drug
but the one in the corner
why because after the takes we have
another one fresh coming in and it's as
if that rook you are never left white is
winning immediately
resigned any questions I think it's a
pretty straightforward position okay
another position that I've brought for
you is from this very exciting game
between two legends of the past the
player with the white pieces is Viktor
Korchnoi everybody must have heard of
him right he was a vice champion for
many many years and his opponent with
the black pieces is Miguel neither again
a very famous Grand Master of the past
of not not so distant past even and of
course everybody knows the knight of
defense rather not of Sicilian defense
sure and in this position cautionary
played very enterprising lis he reached
his position he sacrificed a piece for
two very strong points on the sixth and
the seventh and at first glance we look
at the position and we are like wait a
minute
black is attacking that pawn three times
white is defending it twice excuse me
and white cannot defend it a third time
it looks like that with a fall of that
one the whole white army just falls
apart even though it's right to move it
looks like what can he possibly do about
it but of course quarry calculated
further and he saw that he has a very
very good continuation in this position
again it's combined on tactical ideas
but also a beautiful positional concept
that is also going to be shown one ideas
tactical and other ideas positional a
combination of the two try to think to
yourself if you were here is white what
are you going to do you're about to lose
the pawn on e6 the position collapses
well I'm going to show you because this
is really a it's very difficult and B I
want to show you more stuff I don't
wanna waste time look what happened
quotient I played f4 super just a
supreme move now in the game after some
thinking neither played the move 8 6 and
after f5 you can imagine that white just
won precisely because now that wedge of
pawns is just paralyzing everything ok
let's see I
have the rest of the game here here here
white just went all over okay we can
analyze this further but here in resign
there there's a part of the game where
both side blunder I don't want to go
into this because it's not interesting
my point is to explain to you that this
position once I play a 5 is just winning
this is a winning position if you put in
the computer even though material is
well just about even a piece for three
points the computer says that point is
up like a piece or rock some enormous
amount because it's completely
paralyzing all the pieces everything is
safe so the big question was wait a
minute didn't you say that this was
attacked three times after f4 why didn't
he just take that down pawn
well we understand that in this position
you can play you cannot play for example
Knight X the knight has to stay if you
want to take you have to take with the
rock of course the Queen is out because
the rook is behind it of course if
Knight takes then it's very easy the
rook would have taken and let's say the
rook takes the Queen will sacrifice
because we're about to make a new Queen
right here black would have to block
we're going to just trade notice that
white is up a pawn with the easiest of
wins a pawn up ending is the easiest one
of the easiest ending to win because I'm
just going to bring my king this way I'm
going to try to create a passer well of
course this is just elementary but so
that's easy but the question is after f4
what happened if he goes rook takes a
six why didn't he do that well the
answer is lies in the following idea
rook takes a six again if you take with
the night I will sack my queen for it
because I'm about to make a new one so
of course Queen takes now why it's
surprisingly trade Queen's at first it
looks suicidal what is he doing he is
now down a piece for two pawns and those
two pawns are isolated and doubled but
watch the beauty of this position f5
the night-night must come back here and
now he plays h5 and there is no way to
get the King out of the box in just no
way if you're going to go g6 in the game
I think h6 was analyzed mostly but if
you go here then I'm just going to play
eight six
do as you please you can move unites or
lets you take the pawn I guess it's also
logical now my king is going to go king
up up up take this one then I'm going to
go side side side take this pawn and
then I'm going to just mark respond all
the way and notice that the poor King
and Knight are just as clumsy as they
can be so another alternative would have
been to play eight six and again many
moves would win but the beautiful line
is g4 g6 the point
that's why h6 was played so white cannot
play h6 himself but now watch what white
can do f6 pawn takes pawn takes and once
again the king is in jail no way you can
get the King out of this bind I have one
task in my life to go with the king all
the way to here take this pawn March
March March March March just winning
very aesthetic right on the king so does
the king look our king and the night are
completely here as many moves as you
want it's going to take me 1 2 3 4 5
moves to take the pawn then 6 7 8 9 10
11
you cannot stop it even if my king was
somewhere in another room and had to
make that maneuver you still couldn't
stop me the King can just mark down like
this
the knight cannot go away from f8
because I'm going to make a queen just
help us beautiful idea by Kirchner the
beauty of just how it can be presented
with very few pieces even in an endgame
this seems to be so tedious or or you
have to calculate but sometimes there's
just such beauty in anything like this
and then I'm going to show you of course
what I call a desert like a position
that's not super instructive but kind of
cute and very beautiful about the art of
chess but let's take a look at this
position at first we see it and we think
how interesting can this be each side
has a pawn on his seventh rank
and each side has the rook boat
attacking the opponent's pawn and
defending is the White King is on c8
blocking spawn and the black King seems
to be free roaming on a6 however in this
position white wins and believe me if
you haven't seen it before there is no
way you're going to figure it out
it's just so tricky it's really this is
called luscus maneuver Emmanuel Oscar
had come up with this idea really very
very clever
so let's try to understand what happens
I can tell you one thing if it's black
to move then he draws why because he can
play King a7 for example but it's King
on a 7 the White King can never show
itself because I'll always check you
even blocking is not a solution because
I can just take and I have my own pawn
to Queen and stuff like that this is
just a lone pawn versus nothing but in
this position white wins thanks to a
very very elegant maneuver and again I'm
hoping that you will enjoy and again it
the chances you will have this ending is
not very high but the imagination again
so qb8 I left him I have to move the
pieces sorry King ba and simply threaten
to Queen the pond what is blacks only
moved to avoid this disaster rook check
forest now if the King goes back then my
king we go to a7 and I'm very happy so
King a8 the king is hiding behind the
skin using it for shelter now there are
no more checks what is my only move to
stop the pond from Queenie
Roxy to only move now I'm going to go
check now realize that if the King goes
ever to the B file then my King goes to
b7 and you have no checks I'm going to
Queen my pawn and win it so you always
have to play King ta file your King go
King b6 or king b5 and I'm just winning
so King a5 now white plays King b7
what's my ID Queen
what is your only move you must check me
you don't have any fancy ideas and again
I'm behind the king
my idea is to Queen we already know that
the only move to stop it is rook here
and once again we check we know that if
the King even dreams about going to the
B file then white is going to play King
b7 protected from checks and upon Queens
so King a4 we already know what white
wants to do he brings the King here
wanting to Queen black must check King
a6 threatening to Queen so you go here
and now check a pattern is emerging
right that's already obvious King a3
very nice now it becomes a tiny bit
harder now why place the move King b6
King b7 is useless because after check
we can just repeat King b6 what is my
threat now if you white what is white
threatening I'm not threatening to Queen
because my king is not supporting the
Queen square but my king is holding the
point yeah said rook takes f2
distracting the rug when the rook the
overlord loaded rook will take then I
make my queen and I'm upper Queen for a
rock so what does black have to do he
must check and now King a5 Roxy to is
the only move as we already well know
now rook f3 check the King has to go
backwards doesn't matter anymore B 2 or
a 2
now that the rook and the King are
aligned together rook takes f2 pinning
the rock giving you no time if white
would have done this before then black
would have just taken the pawn but that
was the idea of pushing the blocking all
the way to the seventh rank so that he
is lined up with a rope to a skewer and
then we skewer and after rook takes we
Queen and white his winning the only way
to win but a pretty efficient one very
very nice any questions
you guys are looking a bit in shock when
I saw at first I was also in shock it's
very very yet it's a very it's an
amazing maneuver
okay guys in closing I'm going to show
you one last position that was really
really one of my the most beautiful
compositions I am really really
infatuated with it I have to say and we
have this position okay obviously a
composition not from a real game when
you first look at the position if you
just saw it in a diagram or in a
newspaper on adjacent board to your game
you think the point is just wasting his
time black is about to make a new Queen
right here the knight even with a
chopper can't stop it right it's like
looks over so bye-bye why is--why
playing on but believe it or not the
requirement of this composition is white
to move and draw looks impossible but he
can do it let's try to understand how
and why the first thing is to always
think when it's a requirement to draw a
win is how how do we achieve it how do
we achieve a draw what are the chances
here that this is going to be like 50
move rule yeah I don't think so so you
have to think maybe there's going to be
elevator perpetual check or maybe still
made you have to think in those kind of
directions but when you look at the
position one thing must catch the eye
especially when you know that this is
not an ordinary position there's a
requirement and something unique is
going to happen such as a draw in the
seemingly lost position you notice that
the black king is still mated
right the black king is stuck behind
this pawns and Bishop and and those are
not very mobile the bishop can move but
not so easily
lest we forget that our past pawn here
is held by the bishop if the bishop gets
some ideas I might have my own Queen too
so now we have to think to yourself mean
how do we take advantage of it all we
have is a knight so if I have a night
where do I want my knight to be I think
so chill right the e6 square getting
this hitting this very logical okay
so we can try all kinds of things for
example Knight f6 e to 94 t1 you can
play 95 check
I will take it you will make a queen but
I have an extra bishop
we both Queen and I have an extra bishop
and white will just lose prosaically so
we have to try neither fate and that's
the solution
Knight f8 so II 296 a 1 equals cream all
right now we already know that in this
position if we play 97 for example and
the bishop takes it and the King takes
it then it's black to move with an extra
queen and he is easily going to check
the King stopped the pond from queening
probably pick up some points that even
in the end he has two seconds Queen and
it's going to be just another point that
just runs away it makes a queen in whip
yeah so now we think that's off wait a
minute I have an idea if I queen my pawn
and if you dare take it I'm going to
play Knight c5 Jack King b6 is the only
move Knight d7 Jack King a6 is the only
move and I've stolen a perpetual charge
all right then I'm in it Queen so now we
think that soft well was it really that
simple now now it's black the movie nice
as well I can't very well take the Queen
and now the position is not very
impressive for me I even have to be
careful because if I if Knight if the
White Knight gets to give a check the
bishop will take it my queen here might
be checkmate we really have to think
about stuff like that but he says me I
have a whole queen up for the taking
here I can't do it right away because
he's going to perpetual me but I know
that the queen is waiting for me to be
captured what can I do in the interim
what can I afford to do
you know because if I go Queen a5 check
then maybe 97 check and you'd have to
take and the Queen will take not winning
not good but if I know that they have a
queen waiting for me to be taken and I
know that this night is about to steal a
perpetual for me yes I can afford to
give up my queen for the night so again
the pendulum is turned what is going on
now is white losing if you just take
this Queen Bishop takes this Queen and
of course an extra piece and I'm going
to take this point even if I have to
sacrifice ship my pawn black pawn here
is going to run and win so what is going
on one second we think that black is
just easily winning then we find a
maneuver with the knight with all kinds
of ideas then we Queen our own Queen and
then black sacrifices that we looks to
be going to have to enter a piece down
ending so what are we going to do with
white well white has a monster move here
and again the lesson here since this
position obviously this kind of type of
thing is very unlikely to help in your
games but again thinking out of the box
using your imagination and not deducting
not cancelling the absurd ever white
played Queen takes b6 check a shocking
move well obviously if the king takes
I'm just going to take the Queen now
white is winning this is really ironic
right that's impossible if the pawn
takes and the white takes that takes the
Queen Black is stalemated the blocking
is terminated there's no move
so you said okay this is all good and
beautiful but what if I just take with
my queen save my Queen and win your
Queen
well now white plays this little move
King to c8 and all of a sudden the black
Queen has no moves despite being up a
whole queen black is not winning because
my only free movies here and what does
this do now the white King is stalemated
so what are my options
if I go here the pawn will take if I go
here the pawn will take if you go here
stalemate you can try Queen to c6 jack
but the ending is going to be a draw
after pawn takes you must take
King c7 only move is to push the pawn no
other legal moves I take it and now it's
a race push push push
move the King push push
Queen Queen check and of course black
has no winning chances whatsoever in
this position his pawns are very loose
and white is checking him he has to be
careful not to stop losing pawns and
lose the game so this is definitely not
a winning try for black so most likely
he would have to concede in this
position that he has no win and he
doesn't and after this here King here
Queen d6 and stomach very nice
composition I think now I like it
Oh guys guys you are we are done for the
day thank you very much for
participating and I wants you next week
but maybe another time